3d obstacle why did that squish oh why
isn't jiggling so precariously why are
you squishing like that harpin where
would there be a harpin oh son did you
lose an arm over there aw crap well this
is fun
oh come on Oh pacman creator full well
if I know anything about pac-man it's
sure that he's blue son of a [ __ ] hey
man looks like this scary-ass
[ __ ] over here holy [ __ ]
Oh such a dignified top out indeed let's
see what monstrosity we created lair
escaped why am i escaping the lair
garrison I told you a nap Oh No
okay earthquake simulator survived 30
seconds oh it's just like living in LA
hahahaha well okay so far oh okay take
two I'm just gonna stay on the cache
because okay never mind then oh this
earthquake is curious oh okay all right
I'm okay I'm okay I'm okay I'm gonna be
okay lovely a slam I'm just gonna say no
okay just my son got exploded
don't worry his body parts will cushion
the blow of the earthquake all those
blades almost came precariously close to
my bought okay so far so good
who knew stairs could be so fun or so
dead oh okay maybe if I just two flips
down the stairs no
Oh Oh it's like some horrifying gory
pinwheel yeah I'm skipping rope with my
own intestines son does it feel oh wow
hey we're actually might make it oh all
right you could ease we're going on a
jet fossil go right to it maybe we fly
upside down we'll be just fine didn't I
get an epic victory on this exact same
level wise kid their slow motion what's
my objective my butt come on am i alive
[Music]
fine arena welcome to fight arena
version - all right Who am I fighting
you missed me douche bag thanks you
killed my son and made by let go wonky
well I didn't need that anyway what did
you even do goodbye thank you are you
done
oh I'll get to you later I need to let
go
Cuddy's you are supposed to like oh
you're supposed to stay with us like
okay now it's weird
Oh chucka get down get down come on oh
come on
no no what am i doing what's going on
here what you deserve old man this is
just what you deserve
multiple who is the one that is keep
playing it but it keeps killing me oh no
don't do it
I gotta grab another sword you're just
gonna stay right there and you're not
gonna do a damn thing I thought oh I
thought I could get it with my face but
apparently I'm trying to get it with my
butt HR brg slow motion oh I blocked him
with my butt you're welcome Ani two
percent possible Beauchamp okay okay I
think I'm okay though just oh okay
love me love me oh you love me so good
can you do it whoa can I do what GZ just
turn throwing harpoons at me come on
swing you douche oh that hurt oh come on
let go of my legs stopped working
against the wall and let go
oh how are you dead you torqued to death
nah ain't gonna score on me see wait a
minute know what all DJ B's I rip off
your balls and your balls and Jung go to
Superman that ho get out of here
Justin Bieber Justin Bieber [ __ ] arena
fight version 3 I want to a new
dastardly Damons what do you got for me
two ninjas well ok this again don't kill
me please
oh thank goodness gracious thank
goodness you're okay kid okay go lean on
back here horse cavalry if that's what
your name really is what is your boss
[Music]
[Applause]
well if I knew it was gonna be an RC out
of came earlier oh what a pleasure
oh boy against you Oh clobbered the crap
buddy boy all right you can't run on an
obstacle oh you got shot in the balls
did you well Santa Claus went through
much worth in Vietnam delivering all the
presents wearing that war was not a fun
time what the hell is going on here
Oh so super we stuck our dad is dangling
like a stocking here here we go lowly
the blazing sweat on me I say this is
going swimmingly oh you missed me douche
oh why why would you do that flip there
we go no no no no no I'm still alive oh
you miss me old-fashioned go bye son I
didn't need you for this next part you
were to just hinder okay
Oh Bonjour LeapPad get Malevich our dead
Baba is dangling lure half you know the
only half that mattered top is such a
bit we're going to be fine I just yeah
yeah okay okay
all right then expose I know what expose
means another fighter in and wonder
what's gonna happen to me Oh No dry air
spreading at Micucci lady
Oh your chain
Oh golly you deserve awesome Jenna
whoa that's what I'm talking about let's
see what you can do mr. smiley face what
oh that's easy
I practically ushe oh I know what else
is a shot a mysterious sound of death
well good thing I had my chair defense
or else that never would have gotten
through there we come on get out of the
way chair not trying
seriously share we had a thing but you
need to move on now you need to move on
oh come on chair really you're gonna
block my path you piece of crap
yeah seriously thank you geez Paul's
asked you guys like that out there
you like when Santa torques it for you
yeah go but although come on right
through Santa cerebrum again I have
minor brain damage Santa has a fighter
bro there's something a master sales go
to the battle simulator
oh I see why did that right a mugging
dong carp and run for pros that's
exactly what I'm so gonna get me whoo
you got me oh come on
[Applause]
oh I slide more you don't know this but
I can fly
[Applause]
[Music]
impossible 200%
well it doesn't see oh okay
charging headfirst was a bad idea I'm
gonna send my son to fight you oh that's
right
slide like a bee oh that's up my boy
that is up my bird talks come on oh oh
crawl son okay now I use my son to blow
up that okay oh oh
use my son's death to cover my escape
what is that my son's heart on my butt
ah I've always got my son's heart close
to my butt Go Go guys [ __ ] co-op up
in this [ __ ] No
[Applause]
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you want to see
more happy wheels right now check the
description or click the annotation for
the full happy wheels playlist and if
you want to see more happy wheels in the
future please click the like button to
let me know thanks again everyone and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye